okay should be live
here
hi shorter stream
today about two and a half hours to put
in um I want to fix the mooba I really
want to fix the Moa today it's a really
cool project but it's getting it's just
getting held back by the uh the
baselines training all that nonsense at
the moment
so we have these
WB graphs I
believe you should have finished up
yesterday that out of the
way um is this
it no previous
one okay
so in this run
here something definitely just broke in
the environment at some point but then
even before that it really didn't make
any sense
um I think what we're going to do here
today we're going to just go to the main
boxs we're going to see what's happening
around when one of the game end ends
and we're going to see if we can fix
training uh based on that I think it
should actually be fairly doable now
because we have scripted
opponents whereas before we had the
whole thing with like selfplay and a
whole bunch of additional variables uh
we didn't remove selfplay that's still
very
important but um I don't think it should
be the default setting for simpler tests
like the simpler test is just can you
beat
a kind of dumb scripted
opponent
and I think that'll be nice to be able
to
uh okay so it looks like there were some
uncommitted stuff
here oh I didn't even commit this did
I that's okay
run and we're going to have to start
adding some prints I
believe just because um
I don't think there's a good way to
debug
this outside of
that like it's you can't really run the
debugger nicely through
Python and
uh okay
so basically What's Happening Here is
that radiant should never win because
for radiant to win the model has to
learn enough to beat the scripted
opponent and like that's simply not
going to happen in this tiny little
amount of train data
here should probably just put the Moa up
here so in case anybody's new they can
see what this is so here's our uh here's
our
mooba we can just let's see watch who's
cool to
watch yeah so here we have like MOBA
agents
do I just want to print out the tower
States
okay so we print the tower
so I'm a little concerned how long this
might
take specs double gets
Tower there no I thought I had one of
these
offset yeah there we
go and then we just do power Health like
this
go
um I'm going to have to mess with some
configs
here maybe not
maybe if I just do one in one like
this mile mode train back
native
win okay though that's incredibly fast
so dire wins a
so this is zero
here
ah
okay so here we get our
first radiant
Victory where radiant has
actually done well
here but this doesn't make any
policy okay M script
opponents
and PID is greater than or equal to
five this is where it gets scripted
there's no randomizing of teams or
anything
called it's kind of weird that this does
this appears to get called
I mean is it possible that the towers
just got such low HP that the minions
took
them but no cuz you see right here it
says that they actually they have very
high levels as
well I don't see how you would have high
levels yeah let's just comment this and
let's see
if that changes
anything I don't think so though how did
they get level
Towers there the in the inhib towers or
whatever
right we'll see if we still hit it
welcome YouTube folks we're currently
trying to figure out
what's wrong with these experiments on
this
MOA um essentially the opponent should
be way stronger than our agent and
something is some there's something
weird with like the way I don't know
it's training or something
that like there's just no way that I
believe that the agent is trained to be
this good this
stupid maybe I should log their position
as well
continuous let's see if they're actually
at the enemy
ancient when they win the
uh I don't know about
this this kind of fundamentally doesn't
make sense to
me I might I don't
zero this is X comma y
right this is like at the enemy ancient
then this is at the enemy
ancient and then
almost this is so
weird I mean none of the other oh no
this one is too we have two
players they're like
at the enemy ancient
possible is this like crazy long episode
length
okay
um there's another option here as well
if we just set the learning rate
to set the learning rate to
zero basically confirms that there's
something screwy
right CU if it's not even going to learn
there's no way a random agent is going
to beat this like scripted boss
I mean really the only thing I can think
of
is somehow the scripted Bots are either
getting stuck
or I mean it's got to be that somehow
we're calling the script on all the
players or something like
that okay no so here with no
learning in 4500
ticks so only a few minutes of play I
think it's it's meant to be like 10
ticks per second or five ticks per
second um not a crazy game
length they're
winning
and you see you have a level
20 a level 20 agent
this is where we do the script todayi
right
this just no
way
right like there's just no
way okay this is actually this is
getting
called 5 6 7
89 e
how are these things getting
levels it shouldn't even matter if
they're getting levels though cuz they
shouldn't even be able to go to the
enemy ancient
right I mean like even in 4,000 steps
they're not going to just Meander over
over to the enemy ancient that's not
going to
happen I know we'll do this [ __ ] see
what happens
me okay that's kind of
silly unused variable should not be an
so now there should literally be no way
for them to win cuz they're not even
honestly I'm kind of
surprised that we haven't seen any
um it's so weird because it does seem
like it's legitimately winning the game
but that just shouldn't be
this not going to
work okay we got to do it this way
I think what other information I would
want
ancient it's just bizarre because it
seems like legit victory
I wonder if
there's no there can't be like a glitch
that's letting you hit it from across
the map cuz like lots of towers are
taken that's
scope man what could this be then I mean
we have all the evidence
here we got
Towers like can I see um or like the
tower where's the Tower
data okay
Towers 4 5 6
789 look these towers here are taken
right these towers are all
taken and
then it's wait the first one two three
four five six
nine okay and
then this Tower is the first one on the
enemy that's team the taken and these
are good and this one is taken and these
ones are
good and then
18 like the last few Towers
this is team
Zer
radiant I mean uh
ancient
taken
one this an inhib well there's no rule
that you have to take
okay but then like Tower 12 here which
is the
13th
um
man okay and if we look at the enemy
the rating it's
at it's this one right yeah so it's at
26 you can see that this
player is right by the uh the
ancient so it's actually there in place
to be able to to do something about it
to actually
fight and what did we say it is one two
three the radiant
tank should
be yeah so our tank is taken their
ancient our tank is level 27
their tank is level
26 it's at
how's it going
Ron
names
19106 YouTube might have eaten your
message as well sometimes it eat me it
eats messages if you don't see your
message pop up here I don't see
20 oh wait did I do this wrong hold
on question incoming
soon
here 26 okay now this is
good and then Tower
y so
106 so actually a whole bunch of them
here and
then wait Tower
x
oh yeah look look it's
glitched you see
this I figured it out well I figured out
what's happening I don't know why yet
but
basically the entire enemy team is at
our
base but they can't kill it for some
reason so their entire team is there
wailing on our
base they've taken all of our Towers
pretty sure all the towers right
yeah they've taken all of our
Towers um except
for the ancient and they can't take it
for some
reason and then our guys are all over
the map and somehow this guy meandered
far enough over probably by farming them
hm want to add moral M to puffer called
robot Warehouse robotics Warehouse
doesn't use petting zoo multi gym API
OBS and actions or 2D numpy Rays yeah
that's totally fine so um that's what we
do anyways
like would this be doable yeah of course
do you think I can expect any speed UPS
um yeah it
depends oh you're happy to make a PR oh
cool open source M even better yeah so
what you'd want to look at is you're
going to want to look at our Dev branch
on I mean you know multi-agent
environment with like a fast API I mean
here's one that's pretty darn complex
that runs a million steps per second
right all of our M's are like
this and we have them all in this format
as well right here's multi-agent
snake we've got lots of things like
this so the what what you're going to
want to do for this and there aren't
really docks on this yet because this is
part of the next update it's in Dev at
the moment
you're going to go puffer Li
environments and then ocean is our first
party set of environments and there are
lots of nice examples here um so let me
think of a good one to give
you
multi-agent I could even give you like
the Moa as an example it's just like
there a bunch of extra things in
here let me give you just put you in
snake first we we have some extra files
like I need to get rid of the old scyon
ones or whatever but um here if I go to
snake.
py nope sorry c snake. py new
version um here you can see this is a
little tiny
wrapper and pretty much all you have to
do is Define single OBS and action
spaces so the OBS and action space per
agent like this and then what this does
is this is going to give you data
buffers that's like the same format that
you're expecting like you know P
observations and actions uh except that
if you run this with vectorization this
will be in shared memory for you so that
will give you a big speed up because you
avoid an extra copy on
everything and you get self-observations
actions rewards whatever and you just
run your sim to write directly into
these
buffers we do this
with oops we do this with C or scon
usually so here here is our scyon bind
layer this is what we passed to you can
see here here are all the M's being
created yeah YouTube swallowing messages
you can either post on Discord or on uh
twitch because I'm also live on Twitch
but uh briefly let me finish explaining
here so
like this is where we're passing in
slices of those numpy arrays that you're
using for observations and then we're
doing simulation directly into those
shared rays and so you have like a fully
worked code example of that here and
several of them uh in the ocean
directory generally so if your sim is
fast you know you can go really really
fast with puffer because you don't get
held up by Jim or you know gymnasium
petting zoo any of the janky like
dictionary processing and stuff that
they have
there that's generally uh
I mean we get like a million steps per
second train on some of our MS
oh you know what we should do with
this post the tower
locations YouTube not allowing me link
it in the
Discord
discord.gg
stream good snake yeah you just link it
in the Discord and I'll open it up on
stream and maybe I can give you some
pointers
it's literally just
discord.gg SLP
puffer oops chair's in the way literally
just
meantime I bet you the tower is getting
pulled
we've got a rather nice little Discord
server here going with uh puffer people
136 online and where's the
can I share in general yeah you can post
links we don't have we don't have weird
rules you can just do stuff I I don't
even have YouTube set up to filter it
just does it automatically and I can't
figure out how to turn that
off okay so Tower 23 is at 106
19 is this where it
hey so this is the original position of
the tower the tower didn't get moved
oh
cool yeah this would be
oh yeah this is a this is a perfect
fit what's this written in is this numpy
yeah huh
interesting
so okay um I don't do you know how fast
this is
roughly hello
Frodo was my hair that much of a mess
[Laughter]
here no sadly not well time it right so
here's okay it depends how much you want
to get into this this is actually like a
match made in heaven for puffer lib so
if you want to just put this like Port
this over to use our python on API uh
you will remove all of the bottlenecks
of gymnasium or petting zoo
vectorization and you will get like a
linear speed up with more cores if you
then want to push this into scyon or C
I'm confident you can have this thing
training at a million steps per second
on a single
GPU there's absolutely no reason you
can't have this thing training at a
million steps per second it'll probably
end up being this length or shorter in
just native c um
yeah so up to you how much investment
you want to put in for that but if uh if
this is something that you'd be
interested in I'd be more than happy to
advise and uh you know point you in the
right direction and even uh I could even
get you know potentially a couple
additional people from the Discord who
might want to help you on
this I mean you found like an ideal use
case for puffer and I would be very
happy to support this project cuz this
is like a very nice industry adjacent
thing only stipulation is it's got to be
open source and if you want like you
know full puffer support on it just like
we get to Chuck it on the website as a
demo uh at the
end lowest friction way to use your
vectorization so initially it kind of
depends on whether this thing it says
it's a gy EnV but it depends whether it
is actually a gy EnV or not right so
the lowest performance way to use puffer
um the lowest performance way to use
puffer is to just like wrap an existing
gymnasium EnV with puffer lib do uh
emulation gymnasium puffer EnV that's
going to be like Lis perf after that
it's you use in our Dev Branch you use
our new like native version and you just
like match the python up to what we have
there that'll get you a substantial perf
over for gymnasium and then after that
you push to scyon or C and that's like
50 to 100 times
faster with jy's ve yeah but jy's
vectorization sucks is the
problem I don't know have you seen have
you seen the
paper so like this is kind of how we got
puffer lib off the ground is just by
beating gym vectorization by a huge
margin
right flattening OB so I lost the agent
Dimension oh no no no no you do wait you
lost the agent
Dimension okay so the way that that
wrapper works let me explain
whatever okay so the way that this
wrapper
works thank you so like uh you have some
agents that have observations now if
they're already
flattened then they should look like
this right where you have observations
per
agent and then a single environment is
going to give you a bunch of
observations like
this and then you're going to stack
together multiple environments oops
stack together multiple
environments and you just get like a
two-dimensional
array okay so this is like the standard
of if you want to have everything be
flattened like
this now this doesn't support structure
data right so when you actually have
structured data what you end up having
is in a multi-agent environment right
you have
like I don't know like
whatever you have like dictionary
OBS um and what puffer does is it will
flatten these you are correct it will
flatten these so you just get like a
single flat array but the thing is we
give you a function to undo
it yeah so the reason that it's doing
that is because oh it's so that's
actually okay that's their fault that's
not my fault let me tell you how to fix
that so Jim is not multi-agent API you
cannot do multi-agent observations with
gym so when they say this is a gy m that
is a lie um we do have multi-agent
support you just need to use the other
rapper and match the petting zoo API
instead of the gym
API this is why uh this is why RL is
such a mess because like everybody
abuses these apis and like defeats the
point so this is our gymnasium puffer en
right this is is what you were using
well in the same file same thing we have
a petting zupa for n right and this is
for multi-agent now because this uses
the petting zoo API they do a bunch of
stuff with dictionaries and whatnot
that's slow it's slow on the order of
like you get tens maybe hundreds of
thousands of steps per second you don't
get millions Co it's not crazy slow
you'll still get tens of thousands right
and like the thing that slow is not our
rapper it's it's petting zoo um so you
use this this will get you what you need
and then the only thing that you have to
do uh agent OBS to agent times OBS this
will get you agent comma OBS I don't
know if you have structured observations
but if you do have structured
observations that need to be unpacked in
forward pass we handle this as well this
is one of the core things that puffer
lib is good
at uh let me see if we can find you an
example
here I don't know we've maintained net
hack very well but like if you look at
this net hack thing this is a good
example you just call nativized
tensor and you just make sure that you
save um this D type thing from your
environment and this will let you unpack
and recover structured observations if
needed so that's the deal with this
stuff let me know how that goes and if
you run into any trouble you can ask me
here or on Discord write a wrapper that
takes the fake gy M to petting zo M and
then use puffer Li wrapper yeah that's
going to be the quickest way to get just
something working and then you can see
how fast that is and see if it works for
you um I think generally though
depending on what your objectives are
here you could make this thing just like
a hilariously fast um you could make
this thing hilariously fast like if you
actually implemented this the way that I
would do it with puffer native I can
almost guarantee you that you solve that
environment in like a minute you'll just
solve the whole environment in a minute
yeah so let me know how that goes and uh
I mean if this is for research I will
tell you that the other cool advantage
of um of making it like actually fast
enough and putting it to low level is
you get it put it on web really
easily so uh yeah do low friction first
but afterwards like you get to make cool
demos like
this right where you get to just put
your agents online and like now we get
to watch the agent play the
game so it's
how exactly is puffer native interface
so much faster than Jim en ignoring
vectorization I understand how puffer
Veen is
faster um 100 wait hold on one sec
Captain uh 100% for research Works while
I Happ to make a PR and I to puffer
thanks for feedback absolutely so how
exactly is puffer native interface so
much faster than gym ignoring
vectorization well you can't really
ignore vectorization because the thing
is it's co-optimized to be extra fast
with puffer livs
vectorization um if that makes sense so
like if I were going to do this MOA EnV
as just like let's say I were just going
to make it a gym EnV right so first of
all uh I would have the loop over
environments per process it would be in
python instead of in C so we have like
200 environments run uh single threaded
serially in that one process that's all
in C um second of all the data buffers
that are used for observations and stuff
those get passed in from python so the
environment is actually Computing
observations directly into shared memory
which saves you an additional copy and
then on top of that you know there's
several other places when you do go
through vectorization that we save you a
bunch of other copy operations so some
of the optimization from the vector uh
the VM some of the optimization is from
our native API and then there's a lot of
co-optimization to make both of those
things very very fast when you use them
together can get even faster as well I
haven't even started looking at
vectorization in purec yet
puffer
CC someday we happen someday
makes sense using py boy with python to
compute features and rewards wondering
why VC zero copy wasn't doing much well
that's not it so zero copy is a specific
thing
um the reason zero copy is not doing a
ton for you is because your environment
is slow so zero copy is specifically
intended for uh environments that have
like gigantic observations and are very
fast what it does is it instead of
waiting for the fastest M and like
returning you the first M as soon as it
completes what it does is it waits for a
continguous block of environments in
memory to be ready all at the same time
in order to save you an additional copy
so it's a very Niche thing um it's
really cool when it works but it's very
Niche it's not just going to always work
it's one of four different Pathways in
the vector code though like you know
there's several different settings in
ven that are like can be Auto aut
atically tuned based on your
nice got a few folks on Twitch today
welcome also uh anyone watching if you
have not starred the repo yet just
please give it a star we're really close
to
1,200 uh this this rounds it really
helps me out a ton it's free I work on
this fulltime for free um that's all I
ask it just it helps out a
ton more eyes on puffer more
contributors more bug fixes more growth
that sort of a
thing these guys should be in range of
the enemy ancient why aren't they
hitting
so what do we
do exclude friendlies exclude hostiles
this looks good to
me side note is it possible to have a
well performing healthy
run Spain variant set to zero the entire
um zero what does that mean I actually
haven't thought about it land variance
in a
while one minus the
variance
when y true minus y
weird I don't actually use this variable
very
often let's see what it is for like my
Moa
it yeah I don't think I've actually ever
seen
like entirely zero explained variant
that's a new one that's
weird we're using lstms as well do you
have other variable graphs like you can
just link me the wand B up yeah
exactly just link me wand is
easy oh look at that oh you're doing
Mario okay this is awesome I've actually
wanted to see Mario in uh done with
puffer for quite a while so nice job
with
that if you're down to PR the uh at
least like the environment binding when
you're done that would be awesome we
can't put something like this on the web
I don't think because it runs uh python
but
interesting
curves that's
weird uh yeah this clip rack is bad man
this clip Frack is
bad let me check you're probably logging
parameters yeah entropy very
low uh yeah this is this is
Jank 80
mil this reward is insane
this reward is like not scaled
reasonably this is an insane
reward yeah probably I should have just
sat down with you and looked at this
thing a while
ago okay this is a gigantic network does
not need to be this
big
um running mean
this is fine okay yeah this net is huge
there's no way it needs to be -30 is
probably too much if this is getting -30
* -10 this is just insane you never need
to have rewards above like five or 10
something like
that
um this is a tiny embedding
dim pause
multiple make sure your OBS are
normalized reasonably you usually want
OBS between like negative 1 and one or
whatever and that doesn't mean to like
subtract mean out or anything it just
means like divide by the max or whatever
if they have a crazy high
Max yeah this is a pretty sizable
Network you've got you've got rewards
that I can just see are not scaled
reasonably these are just like way too
big um
good batch size nice big
batches what do you
need on does these batches make sense
for what you're doing because your en is
probably pretty slow
6K it's a pretty big batch for something
that slow I guess you have a really long
time
Horizon yeah that's about what you
expect out of pie
boy unfortunately very
slow num M's and
stuff why don't I see like numb M's in
here am I just
blind how many parallel M's is this I
don't see it
here in here
oh you
okay 120 M split across 24
workers I'm surprised that's even
divisible is that
divisible M batch size of
30 so
120 I don't know if you've messed with
batch sizes being different um I would
suspect that you can reduce this
substantially I don't it might be useful
to have a batch size this big I don't
know but the thing that you're doing
here that's
weird so you're running six update Epoch
okay with a mini batch size of
496 and a batch size of
131 so the math that you want to do
here this is the math that you're
missing uh okay 2 to 17 right divide by
was it 4096 was the mini batch
okay so
32 * 6 you're running 192 updates on the
same
see yeah that's the main thing is you're
just you're running so many updates on
this the same data that you're diverging
the policy and you're doing that in
combination with having High scaled
rewards so that's what you got to look
at you got to do some like some you got
to tweak these things and do some short
runs and not have your graphs looking
like
this hyper pram sweep carbs compute
batch size so mini batch yeah so the
thing is that carbs um carbs will find
stuff like this where like it'll find
stuff that doesn't scale
essentially this is what I do to
transform okay it'll find stuff that
doesn't scale like it'll find like these
very aggressive hyperparameter settings
where like if you keep running it the
policy will
collapse I
see um this might be okay
know some people do this and say it
really helps I've also seen people where
in the past it's kind of Bitten them um
maybe it's
fine like you can see here that by 80
million steps you're like 70% of your
updates now you're clipping
well yeah raw rewards are not working
because they're too big like you've got
gigantic rewards you need to like
somehow you know somewhat fix the scale
a little
bit I mean but like I don't know how
this
is is this the policy that you
trained I mean this looks like it's
actually doing stuff which is cool
good these are so unstable
though and you can see that the policy
crashes here is this it yeah policy
crashes over
here do you have train curves here let's
here working on so look right here you
see you you're training well and then it
crashes so the exact thing that I told
you right you're training well and then
around here look it starts
diverging you see because of the
aggressive settings so the aggressive
settings get you to clear the first part
very well and then the training crashes
because these are just these are very
aggressive settings that are not going
to be stable over a longer run
problem if you want carbs to do
something less insane you can take stuff
like the batch and mini batch size and
clip values out of the pram sweep and
just sweep like the more important like
learn rate gamma J Lambda those
prams don't want to suggest many it
depends on your objective right so the
reason that this is bad for your
environment specifically is because you
have a long running environment where
you're trying to get like you know
better and better runs over a very long
span of time so you probably want to
take out stuff like uh the clip
coefficients and things that are it
you're going to want to take away its
ability to make very aggressive
suggestions that aren't going to hold up
for very long you can just take like you
can take the clip coefficients out um
you can probably take like the mini
batch and batch size out you can just
set those yourself um if you're looking
for like a sane starting point for like
update EPO and stuff generally I will do
um I'll do like four mini batches per
batch so like mini batch size equal
batch size over four if that fits in
memory and then update EPO will always
be one if the environment is fast and
then maybe it'll be as high as like four
if the environment is slow that's
usually what I start
go that should help if you just do that
that should help
thanks Stephan open the puff report once
it's table yeah I mean it should just be
like the binding and rapper and stuff
like we did for
Pokemon it can't really I wish we could
put stuff like this on the website but
kind of
can't you can put gifts on the website
as about all you can do you can't put
like the full m online which
sucks wait hold on does this thing have
a speed buff on
it okay the tower has a speed buff on
it that looks like a bug
oh wait okay so this is this one is
wrong this logging thing is
okay so this Tower logging is fixed that
wasn't the bug
though they've got to just not be
hitting the tower right
now terrible
code it work though
it's definitely something with the way
that uh stuff's
quick let's see how that goes oh yeah so
still bugs reply to a message real quick
messenger
DMS the random message
requests when I'm going through my more
normal
still didn't do
anything oh you know what this is I
bet I bet this is the Waypoint being
slightly
off it's all this
uh okay I think I see what's happening I
but I pulled these out of the original
code so it doesn't really make sense to
me
why oh because in addition to the way
points there's also the targeting stuff
right but that should work for this as
well
AOE they have five Vision that should be
fine
this oh
20 by
two they're 20 way points
okay so yeah probably
it's it's probably
this so I need to count these things
then don't I
okay so I was right that the way points
are a bit
go don't I have the same thing with
neutrals no this is the only one that
has way points all
if that actually does it that's a hard
one
why does dire have zero Towers
alive damn okay that didn't fix it well
we'll see why
not the very
kind of weird that this doesn't just
instantly fix it actually kind of
right okay what if I change this to two
then it should be really obvious
right cuz like then it shouldn't even
get to the
ancient let's see about that
right might end this early we'll see we
are going to fix this today but I don't
know I'm going to probably have to splp
the stream because I got some stuff
going on in a
bit okay so this actually now
shows the way points
properly it doesn't even get to the
ancient now right
well that's that's some syntax right
there
is this just out of vision
range I don't think
so not just out of vision range
oops I'm going to try again with
creep vision
let's give him some bigger creep
Vision yeah you get to see very far
creeps might actually seg Fus we'll
see valid Target
go seg fold
as I anticipated
obnoxious I mean this could really be
the reason here
no we still have
this let's still have this
tower I can only assume it's not
scanning the
tower it's like
10422 where this thing
is like look 104
uh 104 20
10322 yeah they're just on these way
points they're like stuck to their way
wait
what oh no this is
this okay
so there's no problem scanning Towers it
seems
did I mess up something with the ancient
specifically
oh this is the pathing that's
fine did some manual Loop
where was the where were did uh we do
the
are do we not set team
here oh we do set
team and including for the ancient right
cuz we do all the ancient we do the
ancient together now with
it that's bizarre
then this should be fine
okay this is what we're going to have to
do with it is we're just going to
basically have to figure out why it's
not like going to the tower uh and I at
least we figured out what's wrong with
this thing
today holy okay well we figured out
what's wrong with this thing today uh I
haven't fixed it yet I got to go do a
couple things CU I've got some meetings
in a bit um but yeah maybe back in the
evening on this hopefully if not solve
it tomorrow uh and we'll get the Moa
thing training and that's pretty much
what we need to ship this en is just to
have a decent trained agent on this
maybe some perf enhancements as well
anyways uh shorter stream for now thanks
for tuning in uh if you want to support
the project for
free feed the puffer Star Puffer like
stars helps us out a whole
ton other than that you can join the
Discord discord.gg SLP puffer or follow
my my X where I follow me on X where I
post lots of stuff about reinforcement
learning that is at jar is
5341 thanks all and see you around